ah The Legend of Zelda Timeline one of
the most infamous timelines in all of
gaming Nintendo's fantasy franchise
unfurls its tale of Grand Adventure
across 19 Mainline games that kicks off
from a rather neat starting point into
three totally separate timelines and
then sort of back again yeah it's an
absolute Minefield of a timeline and
it's not made any simpler by the fact
that Nintendo has already retconned it a
handful of times in the years since it
was first introduced in this Beast
and with tears of the Kingdom further
expanding the timeline what better time
to dive back into The Many Adventures of
Link be they big or small by land sea or
air or just plain weird
hey my name's Adam and this is the
complete Zelda Timeline fully explained
The Legend of Zelda's sweeping narrative
kicks off with well nothing a whole load
of nothing actually well a whole load of
nothing and the odd bit of cosmic space
rain but mostly nothing into this
nothingness come the three goddesses DIN
nehru and Ferrari din the goddess of
power creates land nehru goddess of
wisdom brings order and Ferrari the
goddess of Courage breathes life into
the world and thus the land of Hyrule is
born
or the land that Hyrule will become at
least as the three goddesses depart back
into the heavens they leave behind three
shiny golden triangles which form the
Triforce a magical artifact that's left
in the care of another goddess known as
hylia the Triforce aside from being a
very expensive looking slab of bling
actually grants wishes to those who come
into contact with it those with just the
right balance of the three virtues of
the goddesses power wisdom and courage
will unlock its true potential those who
don't fit somewhat complex Cosmic
criteria will break apart the Triforce
taking a hold of the piece that best
fits their personality and leaving the
other two bits to go walkies or
something to that effect and naturally
when you create a source of omnipotent
power there are going to be a fair few
Romans that want to get their hands on
it and that brings us nicely along to
the very first game in our timeline
[Applause]
Scarlet wood sword sits pretty right at
the very beginning of this timeline and
pretty much establishes all the key
elements of the iconic legends that will
come to know across the timeline and all
of that kicks off with a great big
bloody fight for the Triforce it's the
era of the goddess hylia and demons are
running amok led by a malevolent Demon
King known as demise in order to protect
her people from demise hylia gathers
them all up on a chunk of land and fires
them off into the sky which feels a
little extreme but desperate times I
guess hylia herself stays behind and
eventually defeats demise before sealing
him away in order to finish him off for
good hylia tries to use the Triforce
herself but because she's a goddess she
can't wield its true power so in another
desperate move hylia demotes herself
from goddess to human and I think you
can see where this is going yeah that
demotion sees hylia reborn as a human
but not any old human Zelda she's reborn
as Zelda and so the Legend Starts but
I'm getting ahead of myself okay
remember that slab of land that hylia
sent off into the sky well that becomes
the Isle of the Goddess which eventually
twins itself with the flying island of
skyloft with the bloody battle on the
surface fresh in their memory skyloft
develops a strong military presence
which eventually becomes the night
Academy effectively a small army of
flying cops who protect and serve the
people of the skies and that's where our
pointy eared hero link first comes into
the story he takes part in the Knight
Academy's Wing ceremony and absolutely
smashes it beating his obnoxious peer
grews to first place and the honor of
performing in the ceremony of the
Goddess opposite Zelda right aside from
that great big battle at the beginning
this all sounds bloody adorable but not
for long entering stage left is the
flamboyant Demon Lord Gira him
who's been Unleashed by demise to hunt
down The Reincarnation of hylia AKA
Zelda girohim scours the land before he
finally tracks down Zelda to the skies
and with the help of a devastating
tornado he flings Zelda down to the
deaths below and this is where the next
part of the Legend of Zelda starts to
take shape you see our blonde lad link
is told about his Destiny by the head of
the Knight Academy a wise old keeper of
Legends called gaypora gaypora The Wise
Old owl of a man guides linked to
finding the goddess sword an ancient
weapon left behind by hylia to guide a
chosen hero how is an inanimate object
guiding a grown lad I hear none of you
ask well that's where the sword Spirit
fee comes into play effectively a blue
robot satnav fee guides linked to plunge
down through the impenetrable Cloud
separating Skyla from the lands below
and so begins Link's quest to rescue
Zelda for the very first time well first
time chronologically fortunately Zelda
has miraculously survived her 4. her
rescuer is an old woman who tells Zelda
that she's The Reincarnation of the
goddess hylia and that to unlock her
memories and full potential she needs to
cleanse herself in two temples Zelda
hastens to do just that and regains her
memories in the process all this new
Divine information rattling around her
head triggers an epiphany to strengthen
the seal on the imprisoned demise she
makes the executive decision to travel
back in time to the sacred Temple and
take a nap not any old nap though like a
really long nav a thousand year long nap
but she's nearly thwarted before this
plan can even get off the ground when
she's attacked by Gira him at the Temple
of Time fortunately link shows up just
in time and holds back gear at him while
Zelda and her protector a warrior woman
called impa Escape into the past on
their way out imper destroys the gate
and they pass through so that no one can
follow them with Zelda napping in the
past Link's work is cut out holding back
the hordes of monsters in the present to
help with this he upgrades the goddess
sword with a source of sacred power
which eventually transforms it into the
iconic Master Sword a sword so powerful
it allows him to literally travel back
in time to have a quick conflab with a
prenapse Elder Upon returning to the
present link seeks out the fabled
Triforce and upon discovering it is
deemed worthy of its power and is
granted a wish he wishes for the Statue
of the goddess to be returned to its
original place on the surface where it
handily destroys the Demon King demise
and awakens Zelda from her long Slumber
and with that the story of Skyward Sword
comes to a close hold up that's not how
it ends oh no there's one last twist in
this tale you see that Pratt girohim is
still knocking about and he nabbed Zelda
and travels back in time to reawaken
demise before he gets crushed by a giant
statue link follows in Pursuit and after
an epic battle defeats both girohim and
the reawakened demise with the Demon
King defeated once and for all which as
you'll come to see is something of a lie
his sheer evil and hatred is absorbed
into the master sword which effectively
kick-starts the beginning of a curse a
curse that sees link Zelda and the
literal embodiment of hatred locked into
a never-ending battle between good and
evil with peace returning to the lands
above and below the master sword is
returned to its pedestal inside the
goddess statue waiting for the next hero
to emerge and fight the Everlasting
curse okay I know that that was a lot to
take in but at least we've established
the core elements of The Legend of Zelda
franchise so stick with me
foreign
[Music]
things first the surface lands from the
era of Skyward Sword eventually become
the kingdom of Hyrule the central
location for most games in the franchise
peace extends across the lands for many
generations but after a while rumors of
the power of the Triforce start to
spread and Chaos begins to take rule
with the Triforce at risk its latest
protector rauru the sage of light builds
the Temple of Time supposedly over the
ruins of the seal temple from Skyward
Sword here he locks up the master sword
behind the door of time and places the
Triforce in the Temple of Light which is
sealed away in the sacred realm which
itself is now separated from Hyrule gosh
that's a lot of grandiose titles in the
last couple of sentences to summarize
the Triforce and the sacred realm are
locked away from bad people to further
protect the Triforce the descendants of
the Goddess hylia build Hyrule Castle
next door to the Temple of Time and
established the royal family to protect
it as they're all effectively
descendants of a goddess many of them
are born with special powers and it's
during this time that the addition of
naming their princesses Zelda is started
the years pass by and peace extends
across the lands that is until yet
another wave of evil washes across
Hyrule I guess that curse ain't messing
about in this latest bout of Terror the
people of Hyrule are saved by of all
things a tiny little fella known as a
pickary who brings with him a sword and
a golden light the latest flavor of the
hero of men uses them to restore peace
and seal the evil in a big old chest for
future generations to worry about and lo
and behold that's where we pick up at
the beginning of Minish Cap the smallest
of Zelda adventures in honor of their
little savior Hyrule holds a pickery
festival and legends state that the
pickery will return every century and
guess what it's been 100 years since
they were last seen the festival
culminates with a sword fighting
tournament and the winner of this year's
tourney is a Shifty looking wizard lad
called vati who true to his appearance
causes a scene by breaking open the
chest full of badge before turning
Princess Zelda into a stone statue he
also breaks the pickery sword in the
process to rub salt in the wound and it
turned turns out that the key to saving
Zelda is through the magic of the sword
because we need a reason to explore
Hyrule this prompts a capless link to
seek out the tiny pickery people who
actually call themselves the Minish and
on Route he bumps into a weird Little
Bird hat thing called eslo you see it
turns out eslo is a Minish Sage who's
also Fallen foul of vati hence why he's
a bird Hat Thing eslow joins forces with
link and the pair seek out the Minish
who promptly tell them that to fix the
sword they'll need to seek out four
elements around Hyrule and long story
short link seeks out the four elements
obtains some powerful new items and
defeats and bosses you know normal Zelda
varti however is biding his time in his
quest to seek the fabled Golden Light of
the pickery he learns of the power of
the pickary sword and instead of being
proactive about it he's just happy for
link to do all the hard work this all
comes to a head when link fuses the
elements of the pickery sword to create
the fabled 4 sword which gives the
wielder the ability to quadruple himself
Lin uses this power to see off vati
who's busy draining the light Force out
of Zelda who it turns out is The Keeper
of the pickery's golden light and with
farty thwarted the curses on Zelda and
eslo break and Hyrule is restored to its
former glory peace and Hyrule however
does not last long foreign
[Music]
The Crafty old bastard reappears out of
nowhere and starts terrorizing Hyrule
but yet another legendary hero or should
that be heroes plural stand in his way
when they harness the power of the four
sword and defeat him which seals the old
wizard in the four sword itself
Generations pass as they tend to do
after these Zelda prologues and surprise
surprise vati breaks free he kidnaps the
latest incarnation of Princess Zelda and
hightails it into the night hot on his
heels are the four links that spring out
of the titular four sword and after
collecting up a bunch of rupees and
defeating some monsters to prove their
worth the four Swordsmen confront varti
in his palatial Den with their strength
in numbers the links defeat vati and
Hyrule returns to peace once again but
for how long spoilers not long
[Music]
you see following the four Swords Saga
the kingdom of Hyrule is embroiled in a
bleak Civil War which spreads death and
destruction across the lands amongst all
this Carnage a young mother flees with
her baby into the kakiri forest where
she leaves her child with the sacred
Deku Tree because trees are known to be
very good foster parents naturally the
Deku Tree senses great things to come
from the tiny baby he agrees and the
child grows up within the kakiri
community a community of Elf like kids
who all have companion fairies and never
grow old it's kind of like Zelda's
version of Peter Pan meanwhile the war
eventually comes to an end when the king
of Hyrule is able to unify the sparring
tribes under one Kingdom one of the
leaders of those tribes is a lad called
Ganondorf who swears allegiance to the
king but he should under no
circumstances be trusted this evil
looking bastard is secretly after the
power of the Triforce that was last seen
hidden somewhere near to Hyrule Castle
while he's keeping faced with the King
Ganondorf puts into action his plan to
find the three keys to the sacred realm
precious jewels dotted about Hyrule even
the King's Daughter our latest flavor of
Princess Zelda can sense his evil
ganondorf's treachery comes to her in a
dream and she implores her father to
banish the ginger warlord from the
kingdom a plea that unfortunately falls
on deaf ears the other part of her
prophetic dream was the emergence of a
young boy in a fairy that would counter
the evil of Ganondorf cue another
legendary hero in the form of that
aforementioned baby all grown up and his
pet fairy Navi and it turns out that
he's already got one of the Sacred
Jewels he's a keeper the pair hatch a
plan for linked to nav the remaining
keys to the sacred realm while Zelda
keeps an eye on ganondorf's nefarious
plans before gaining access to the
Triforce to beat the demon Thief at his
own game and so link hustles around
Hyrule to get the last two keys meeting
the people of fire the gorans and the
people of water the Zoras in the process
two races that will crop up a fair whack
across the the timeline so I just
thought I'd name drop them here anyway
link Journeys back to Hyrule Castle keys
in hand but as he's arriving at the
gates to the keep he's confronted by
Zelda fleeing on Horseback with her
protector impa one of the last remaining
members of the sheikah tribe the same
tribe that protected the original Zelda
back in Skyward Sword she's fleeing from
Ganondorf who's halfway through an
attack on the castle all in the name of
stealing a musical instrument but not
any old musical instrument only the
titular Ocarina of Time a magical music
maker that can transport its user
through space and time oh and it's also
a key to the sacred realm which is kind
of Handy with Zelda AWOL Linksys through
their original plan of opening the
sacred realm but this plan does not go
well you see Ganondorf accesses the
sacred realm too and is able to grab the
Triforce of power he's only able to grab
that part as he's a rotten egg and the
other two pieces scattered to the wind
at his mere whiff regardless ganondorf's
invasion of the Sacred realm turns
Hyrule Castle into a literal Hells Gate
populated by nightmares zombies and
monsters and a lad who will pay good
money for ghosts but ignore him anyway
link let's not forget is still a child
and as a result is in no fit state to
counter any of this as he draws the
master sword from its pedestal it seals
him within the sacred realm until he's
the right age to take up his mantle as
the hero of time and so link sleeps for
seven long years watched over by the
sage of light rauru while he's taking
this prolonged nap Zelda is forced to go
into hiding to escape ganondor's forces
and she disguises herself as Sheik a
strapping lad at the sheikah tribe when
link awakes he's greeted by Sheikh who
sends him off on another Epic Quest this
time to break the curses on five temples
around the land and awaken the sages
that Slumber within the endgame lur
Ganondorf into a trap and use the power
of the entire contingent of sages to
lock him within the sacred realm and so
are Plucky adult hero Ventures off high
and low to save the sages and reunite
the old gang a gang of individuals he's
actually met along his travels already
long story short link unites the sages
and heads back to the Temple of time
where he has a long-awaited reunion with
Zelda where she reveals that she's in
possession of the Triforce of wisdom
this reunion does not last long though
as Ganondorf soon rocks up to crash the
party and kidnaps Elder link follows in
pursue and falls right into the Dark
Lord's trap you see link is in
possession of the Triforce of courage
and with all three brought together
Ganondorf makes a play to collect the
full set following a chaotic battle atop
Hyrule castle where Ganondorf morphs
into the boar-like Ganon link is finally
Victorious and aided by Zelda and the
other sages are heroes trap Ganondorf
away in the sacred realm with his
precious Triforce of Power with the
curtains closing on another epic
adventure peace once again extends
across Hyrule but while the people get
peace this timeline gets pure chaos let
me explain
[Music]
right with all the time travel
Shenanigans knocking about an Ocarina of
Time it kind of breaks the timeline and
I mean really breaks the timeline from
Ocarina the chronology splits into three
different strands the first of which is
incredibly Grim that strand follows one
possible outcome where the hero of time
is defeated by Ganondorf which sets in
motion the path to a link to the past
and the original Legend of Zelda among
others yeah Nintendo came up with an
actual canonical path where their
Central hero dies you don't see that in
Mario the other two strands stem from
the opposite outcome where the hero of
time is successful in the fight against
Ganondorf but this is where it gets all
timey wimy the second timeline Branch
sees link return in time to his
childhood and this sets in motion the
path towards Majora's Mask and Twilight
Princess which sees Ganondorf
reincarnated to terrorize Hyrule once
again the third and last branch of the
timeline is the adult Era timeline and
basically sees a world in which the hero
of time vanishes largely because he sort
of has just back to his old childhood
time instead of wiping this timeline
clean Nintendo just doubles down on the
time paradoxes and this sets in motion a
path where Hyrule is flooded to protect
the Triforce which as you can probably
guess leads to the maritime Madness of
the Wind Waker and Phantom Hourglass all
before a new Hyrule is established on a
new continent
so moral of the story you can't exactly
mess with time travel and expect there
not to be consequences I guess
[Applause]
[Music]
right first The Morbid timeline so link
straight up dies during his battle with
Ganondorf during the climactic events of
Ocarina of Time and this sets in motion
Aid path where the demon Thief gains
possession of the complete Triforce
Zelda and the sages are still powerful
enough to seal the ginger Pratt away in
the sacred realm but he takes the full
might of the Triforce with him a shaky
piece descends across Hyrule as the
years Roll by but fueled by Dark Rumors
about a hidden golden Power word starts
to spread about the sacred realm and a
fair few brave souls even try to access
it never to be seen again you see
ganondorf's residence in the sacred
realm has turned it into the Dark World
a place of Pure Evil and Malice and this
prompts the sages to seal the realm off
for good fast forward a couple of
generations and we reach the beginning
of a link to the past the sacred realm
has remained untouched but that all
changes when a flashy wizard lad called
agonim turns up kills the king and
starts stealing the female descendants
of of the sages Princess Zelda just so
happens to be one of those kidnapped and
she sends out a telepathic message guess
she's got psychic powers in this
timeline which is picked up by our old
mate link and his uncle who are
themselves descended from the fabled
Knights of Hyrule link saves Zelda and
escorts her through the castle sewers to
a sanctuary where he is then sent out on
an epic quest to find the mythical
Master Sword before using it to fight
back against agonim after proving his
worth by securing the three mystical
pendants link finally lays his hands on
the master sword which now sits in a
deep dark Forest presumably the Temple
of Time Has crumbled away over the years
after zapping back and forth between
Hyrule and the sacred realm or light and
dark worlds as they're now called link
eventually confronts the evil wizard
atop a giant pyramid in the Dark World
defeating him before taking on the
game's true antagonist Ganon the evil
pig monster who's been pulling the
strings all along link makes short work
of Ganon takes a hold of the Triforce
and wishes for peace to return to the
world and with that we get a brief happy
ending amid this timeline of Doom and
Gloom peace returns to Hyrule as does
the Triforce and even people who died at
the hands of Agony in return as well
jobs are good and Link
foreign
now we get to the bit of the timeline
that let's say is a little bit flexible
I say flexible because Nintendo
themselves have straight up shifted
around the order back in the original
Hyrule Historia the Oracle Games took
place after a link to the past but fast
forward to the release of the Zelda
encyclopedia and the order has changed
with Link's Awakening coming next
Nintendo announced this with all the
Fanfare of a footnote look
there it is
anyway Link's Awakening is next up on
the timeline and sees the very same hero
from A Link to the Past Shipwrecked on
the shores of the Mysterious kohalen
Island after a training Mission and it
turns out that Colin is weird
there's a giant air Atop The Central
mountain and a weird sense of deja vu
surrounding certain Island residents
that he meets and that's because it's
all a dream
well sort of it turns out that color
lint has in fact been manifested by the
consciousness of a wind fish and for
link to escape he'll need to wake said
windfish destroying the island and all
of its inhabitants as a result while he
may be used to saving Kingdom's link
does not hesitate in condemning this one
and he Ventures about on his merry way
to collecting eight magical instruments
that will wake the wind fish and with
the wind fish up from his nap Cohen
shimmers away to be remembered only in
Link's memories which is quite a dark
ending for such a jovial Adventure
foreign
next up we've got the duo of Oracle
games Oracle of Seasons and Oracle of
Ages which again features the very same
link from a link to the past the Oracle
game see a return for the twin Rover
witches a pair first introduced towards
the tail end of Ocarina of Time and who
were instrumental in the upbringing of
the ginger head delinquent Ganondorf
their mischievous game plan to resurrect
Gannon himself through some weird culty
ceremony to this end they infiltrate the
worlds of holodrum and laburna where
they kidnap the titular Oracle of
Seasons and ages DIN and nehru using the
power of the Triforce link is
transported to the two aforementioned
worlds where he defeats the lieutenants
of twin Rover to bring peace and Order
back to their Realms all of this is in
vain however as twin Rover kidnaps Zelda
with a view to sacrificing her as part
of their Resurrection ceremony link
disrupts The Witch's mid-ceremony and
saves Zelda and as a result twin Rover
sacrifice themselves and this brings
Ganon back once again as the ceremony
was only half finished this iteration of
Ganon is something of a brainless Pig a
shadow of his Porky Glory ugh sorry
about that Turner phrase anyway link
defeats the gormless Ganon which brings
the Oracle games to a close
[Music]
centuries pass in the wake of the Oracle
games in which time the Triforce is
split with the wisdom piece remaining in
the hands of the royal family the power
Triforce returning to the steel sealed
Ganon and the courage slab going AWOL
awaiting a new hero to come and find it
enter said hero an apprentice blacksmith
handily also called Link at the
beginning of A Link Between Worlds which
is very much a spiritual sequel as well
as an actual sequel I guess to a link to
the past which means the story is pretty
much a rerun of the snares classic that
said there is a whole load of fresh
story content Within A Link Between
Worlds namely the introduction of a
whole new world called Low rule yeah
technically it's another parallel
universe in the ilk of the Dark World
but it's a little different this time a
link between World season Evil sorcerer
known as Yuga infiltrate Hyrule in a bid
to kidnap the descendants of the sages
so far so familiar while out delivering
a sword link stumbles upon Yuga mid
kidnap and well he Witnesses the evil
wizards straight up to turning a poor
lass into a painting Yuga knocks link
out for his troubles and scarpers back
to his home in Lowell link investigates
further and with the help of a
mysterious bunny eared traveler named
ravio finally tracks Yuga down only to
be turned into a painting himself
instead of living out his days as a
piece of street art link has the power
to switch between 2D and 3D at will
thanks to the timely intervention of a
magical bracelet given to him by ravio
using this newfound gimmick link
discovers that Yuga is surprise surprise
planning on resurrecting Ganon but once
link digs a little deeper it turns out
that there's a whole load more at stake
after Zelda is kidnapped by Yuga and
taken back to Laurel link follows in
Pursuit and discovers the tragic history
of hyrule's dark twin you see it turns
out that Laurel had its own Triforce at
one point which was destroyed when the
people of the land fought over its power
link also meets Princess Hilda a
dark-haired doppelganger of Zelda who
helps him keep Yuga at Bay while he can
track down the Triforce of Courage but
wait there's one more twist it turns out
that Hilda is actually playing link as
she's in League with Yuga and his plan
to resurrect Gannon with the ultimate
end goal of stealing hyrule's Triforce
to replace their own destroyed one this
all comes to a head when link defeats
Yuga and Hilda with the help of ravio
before uniting the hillion Triforce and
as he's a good agar link he wishes on
the Triforce for peace and prosperity to
return to Laurel which brings the game
to a happy ending with not one realm
saved but two
[Music]
right next up on the timeline is the
most inconsequential Zelda Adventure to
date and I do not say that lightly after
saving Hyrule and Laurel our Victorious
blacksmith hero travels far and wide
eventually finding himself in the land
of high Topia the most fashion conscious
of all the Zelda Realms here he takes up
a job listing asking for Heroes with
pointy ears and truly epic sideburns
Nintendo's words not mine to break a
curse that an evil witch is cast on the
princess yup Triforce Heroes is
literally a game about saving a princess
from a cursed jumpsuit long story short
link and a couple of look-alike Lads
this is a three-player multiplayer game
after all venture into a kingdom known
as the drab lands to confront the witch
responsible they find said witch drive
her away and Bobs your uncle the curse
is broken they return to the incredibly
vain Kingdom of hytopia and the princess
no longer looks like a turd so that
counts for a win I guess
right from the frivolity of high fashion
to the decline of the entire Kingdom of
Hyrule damn that's Eternal Whiplash okay
before we dive into the story of the
original 1986 Zelda which sits next on
our timeline there's a little bit of
backstory that we learn later on in its
sequel the adventure of Link in the wake
of the complete Triforce returning to
the royal family of Hyrule successive
generations of Kings used it to retain
peace and Order across the kingdom until
one of them just decided nah this power
might go to someone's head eventually so
that King hid the Triforce of carriage
away and entrusted his daughter Zelda
with the Triforce of wisdom
unfortunately this plan completely
backfired and it cast a spell across the
land of Hyrule which eventually led to
its decline not only that but his Prat
of a son the prince craved the power of
his father and under the influence of an
evil wizard there's a lot of those about
in this timeline puts his sister Zelda
into a long deep sleep finally coming to
his senses the prince places his dormant
husk of a sister in a sacred Altar and
her story is passed down from generation
to generation as the tragedy of Princess
Zelda the first which itself is a little
bit confusing in the context of this
timeline as we've already had a handful
of zelders but hey ho here we are with
Zelda the first anyway all of this was
backstory to the original 1986 Legend of
Zelda remember so time I got back to
that Gannon is back once again because
why the hell not by this point and the
reigning Princess Zelda not sure what
number she is splits up the Triforce of
wisdom into eight chunks which he hides
across the land so Gannon and his
minions can't get their hands on them a
young hero turns up in the devastated
Kingdom of Hyrule which is now a shadow
of its former glory and he finds his way
into the path of impa Zelda's handmaiden
who instructs him to seek out the
hriforce pieces so he can defeat Ganon
he does the end but this ending is far
from happily ever after
[Music]
after defeating Ganon link decides to
stick around Hyrule and help clean up
the mess that Ganon has left and there's
a lot of mess you see ganon's minions
are still running a mark across the
lands and they organize a resurrection
attempt by planning to sprinkle the
blood of link on ganon's charred remains
which is a Bonkers plan but I'm sold
anyway six years pass and on Link's 16th
birthday the crest of the royal family
appears on the back of his hand side
note that little detail about link being
16 an adventure of Link means that the
hero in the original Legend of Zelda was
10 and that fact just blows my mind I
digress link shows the Cresta imber who
regales the history of Hyrule to link
and tells him about the tragedy of
Princess Zelda the first now that he's
come of age input implores link to
search for the Triforce of courage in a
bid to unite the complete Triforce once
again and save Zelda the first she gives
him an ancient scroll which eventually
leads him to the great palace and the
resting place of the final Triforce
piece after an epic final battle with
the guardian deity and a shadow version
of himself link is victorious in uniting
the Triforce he uses its power to awaken
Princess Zelda the first from her long
nap disrupts the attempts to resurrect
Ganon and hey ho peace once again
returns to the kingdom of Hyrule which
brings this branch of the timeline to a
close Well for now at least
but before link can even think about
putting his feet up with a good cupper
it's time to rewind back to that pivotal
timeline split all the way back at
Ocarina of time's conclusion
okay we're back at the ending of Ocarina
of Time or more specifically the first
meeting between Link and Zelda which is
still the first meeting for Zelda but
technically the second for link gosh uh
let me explain right so after defeating
Ganondorf link travels back to his
childhood but retains all of his
memories as an adult Chief leader of
ganondorf's treachery he hightails it to
Zelda to tell her and shows her the
Triforce of Courage on the back of his
hand as proof Zelda believes in
Ganondorf is thrown in jail and the
crisis is averted before it can all kick
off in the first place to make doubly
sure that Ganondorf will never enter the
sacred realm Zelda entrusts Link with
the Ocarina of Time and tells him to
venture far away from Hyrule link hops
on a tiny little opponent just look at
how cute she is and Journeys off into
the Wilderness he travels so far he
literally breaks the fabric of time and
space and haphazardly hops into an
alternate Dimension where he gets turned
into the long dead Spirit of a Deku
scrub yeah did I mention that Majora's
Mask is weirdest hit anyway link finds
himself in the land of termina which is
a strange parallel world of sorts
occurring of times Hyrule featuring a
whole load of characters that look
Vaguely Familiar largely because it came
out two years after Ocarina of Time and
Nintendo reused a lot of the same assets
but we'll give them a pass because the
game's a stone cold banger termina is
having something of a crisis of its own
and by crisis I mean the literal
apocalypse is nigh signposted by a
massive grinning Moon that is about to
crash down and flatten everything after
chatting to a seriously creepy Mass
salesman link learns that the world is
in this situation because a powerful
mask the titular one belonging to Majora
has fallen into the hands of a rascally
skull kid who's up to no good and so
link Ventures off around termina to
right the wrongs in the world and there
are a lot of wrongs the fire loving
gorons are frozen there's a load of
aliens abducting cows and there's even a
disembodied hand emerging from a toilet
remember I did say Majora's Mask was
weird by using the Ocarina of Time link
is able to get through all these weird
little jobs by traveling back in time to
see out the final three days in term in
his life over and over again and he
eventually fixes everything to the point
where he can face the skull kid himself
oh and he also enlists the help of four
handy Giants to literally hold the moon
in place you know which helps it turns
out that Majora's Mask itself is causing
all the Carnage and after a really odd
final battle link defeats the mask
returns it to the creepy salesman and is
on his way to a location that's likely
not as delightfully weird
[Music]
meanwhile back in Hyrule years have
passed since the events of Ocarina of
Time and our old friend Ganondorf is
finally set to be executed for his
crimes he's taken to a sacred Place
known as The Arbiter grounds where he's
executed by A Great Big bloody sword
right to the chest only this doesn't
kill him as he's in possession of the
Triforce of power he survives the
impaling only to be banished to a never
before mentioned Twilight Realm by the
sages you see the Twilight realm is a
parallel world of sorts there's really a
lot of them knocking about in this
franchise that was created when four
light Spirits banished magic wielding
people out of Hyrule this shadowy
Lookout is populated by a race of people
known as the Twilight and when Ganondorf
rocks up with all his evil thoughts and
plans he inspires one of the Twilight a
wrong Unknown Known as Zant to invade
Hyrule this devilish Duo is opposed by
the titular Twilight Princess a last
called midna whose first by Zan and
banished a Hyrule Zant then invades
Hyrule transforms the world into a dense
land of Twilight and turns all humans
into anxiety-racked spirits and that's
all just the backstory for Twilight
Princess Link hasn't even turned up yet
speaking of Link this time he's a wolf
you see as Twilight spreads through the
land of Hyrule it finally reaches the
outskirts of Link's home Village but
instead of turning into a spirit link
turns into a good boy as a result of him
being a descendant of the hero of time
and possessing the Triforce of Courage
speaking of the hero of time he actually
rocks up in this game as an embittered
old skeleton to Dole out sword fighting
tips and tricks but I'm digressing again
so with the help of midna Link Ventures
around Hyrule catches up with Zelda
clears the land of Twilight finds the
master sword in the ruins of the Temple
of Time snowboards with a Yeti fixes a
broken mirror and eventually travels to
the Twilight realm itself to destroy
Zant but that's just half the job done
with Ganondorf back in Hyrule Lincoln
midna confront him in the car throne
room and after not one not two but three
bounce in the ring with him Ganondorf is
finally defeated courtesy of a good
old-fashioned Master Sword to the chest
it didn't work last time but this isn't
any old sword and he loses the Triforce
of power as a result and with Zant and
Ganondorf gone the curse on Hyrule and
midna is lifted and as link turns to
celebrate with her he's shocked by the
true form of the Twilight Princess stand
before him and with that the game comes
to a close when midner says her
farewells to Zelda and Link before
traveling back to her own realm and in
her last act before departing she
shatters the mirror of twilight and
breaks the connection between the two
worlds forever
[Music]
okay several hundred years have passed
since the events of Twilight Princess
and pieces extended across the Realms of
Hyrule especially in the relations
between the hillians and the Gerudo
people the tribe that Ganondorf was born
into but here's the kicker somehow
rather inexplicably if you ask me
Ganondorf is back how you may ask well
he's just sort of Born Again into the
Gerudo tribe ready and willing to tear
the place up he starts by trespassing
into a forbidden pyramid to steal a
mystical Trident before he nabbed a dark
mirror which is remarkably familiar to
the one in Twilight Princess but has
absolutely nothing to do with it for um
reasons to add insult to injury the
demon Thief resurrects are old pal vati
remember him the old wind wizard himself
kicks into life and the evil pair
kidnaps Zelda and her maidens and
enshroud the world of Hyrule in darkness
as is the tradition in Zelda games link
not wanting to suffer about a fomo draws
the fabled force sword which hasn't been
used for Millennia by this point I guess
and he immediately quadruples himself
the quartet Venture around Hyrule fixing
the light World bit by bit before
defeating vati at the top of his
perilously high wind Palace as they
escape the crumbling Palace they're
confronted by Ganon who's also easily
vanquished the links use the foresaw to
seal the giant pig away and with that
the ancient weapon is placed back on its
pedestal awaiting the next time Nintendo
decides to make a multiplayer Zelda
that's not Triforce Heroes right with
another timeline at an end time to
rewind time once again back to that
crucial split in the chronology
foreign
[Music]
split at the end of Ocarina for the last
time promise
this branch of the chronology follows
the timeline that shoots off from the
events in Ocarina where the hero of time
travels back to his childhood but
instead of erasing this timeline Allah
Back to the Future it just creates a
whole new timeline ala Avengers end game
are you still with me I really hope
you've seen those movies
anyway Ganondorf is sealed away as we're
following on from the adult timeline
ending of Ocarina of Time and peace once
again extends across Hyrule by now you
should know that that piece will be
short-lived and lo and behold Ganondorf
is able to crawl his way out from the
death to wreak havoc once again in the
wake of the hero of time having Zapped
back to his childhood and gone off
adventuring to termina etc etc the king
of Hyrule turns to the gods for help and
they choose the Desperate Times
Desperate Measures plan of action so
they seal Hyrule and flood the whole
damn world wow fortunately the good
people of Hyrule Survive by traveling to
the tops of the tallest mountains in the
land and in this new water world a bit
like the movie but definitely not the
movie they emerge from the flood on
isolated Islands across the ocean the
king himself stays behind in the sealed
castle of Hyrule sending his daughter to
the waves above to live out her life
with the common folk albeit with a piece
of the Triforce of wisdom years pass and
Ganondorf turns like a bad Penny
stirring up across the seas from
his den at The Forsaken Fortress he
seeks out and murders two of the sages
and starts his search for Zelda and the
Triforce of wisdom the king also wakes
from islamber and his Spirit takes up
residence in a dashing red boat known as
the king of the red lines the king boat
goes searching for his descendant as
well as for a new hero who can take up
ownership of the Triforce of Courage the
former he finds in the shoes of brash
pirate leader Tetra while the latter he
finds on a Charming Little Island this
strapping young lad also handily known
as link has been searching for his
sister who's been kidnapped as part of
ganondorf's Enterprise to steal young
girls until he finds Zelda which is an
absolutely mad plan when you stop and
think too much about it okay now all the
major pieces are finally on the board
for Wind Waker let's break it all down
okay so link and the King boat Venture
off across the seas to prove his worth
for the Triforce of courage in the
process they save Link's little sister
meet the descendants of the kakiri and
the Zoras who are now little tree
Sprites and dragon birds respectively
and chart a series of maps with a
talking fish after proving his courage
link travels beneath the waves to Hyrule
castle where he grabs the master sword
little side note but I love all the
stained glass windows here that depict
the battle with Ganon and the six sages
for a Macarena of time it's these little
moments that really sell this Bonkers
timeline for me anyway the master sword
is next to useless against Ganondorf and
Lincoln Tetra barely escape with their
lives during their attempted attack on
The Forsaken Fortress and it's at this
point that the king of Red Lions seeks
to move matters along a bit first by
informing Tetra of her ancestry and
uniting the Triforce of wisdom and
secondly in directing link to seek out
the shards of the Triforce of Courage so
they can more successfully put an end to
Ganondorf and so we fast forward a bit
to the section where link has all the
relevant Triforce pieces and can retake
the assault to Ganondorf a lot of things
happen in a short space of time first as
Ganondorf reaches out to take the
completed Triforce the actual King rocks
up and touches it first and wishes for
the ancient land of Hyrule to be
destroyed once and for all to make way
for a better future this irks the demon
Thief somewhere as he kinda had hopes on
ruling over said land but hey ho unlucky
Ganondorf lad Lincoln Zelda kick into
gear and fight off Ganondorf with a
combo of light arrows and the master
sword itself and finally defeat the evil
Bastard with a sword stabbed at the head
which has always felt overly violent to
me especially within the context of the
cutesy cell shaded Graphics anyway Zelda
and Link Escape Hyrule as it crumbles
around them and the King opts to stay
behind like the captain of a sinking
ship and so the never-ending cycle of
Hyrule and the Triforce finally comes to
an end well at least in this timeline I
guess but this story branch is far from
over
[Music]
foreign
who's now back in the guise of tetra set
sail in search of new lands their
travels take them into the haunted
Waters of the Ghost Ship which promptly
kidnaps Tetra and throws link overboard
he awakes on Mercy Island and befriends
the wise old oceans his pet fairy sealer
and the charismatic Captain Lineback
across Link's Adventures to catch the
Ghost Ship he learns that oshas is
actually the local ocean King who's in a
long-running battle against some kind of
evil squid called Bellum and his pet
fairy is actually the Spirit of Courage
Lineback is just plain old Lineback
though so nothing new there onru link
secures another legendary sword fools
around with time once again courtesy of
the titular Phantom Hourglass and
defeats Bellum peace returns to the
season OSHA's turns back into his true
form which is a giant silver whale but
here's the kicker when Lincoln
tetrifying themselves back in their own
world only 10 minutes have passed since
they left on their Voyage which is a
proper ballsy link so awakening-esque
move by Nintendo
and so after their supposedly 10 minute
long adventure in Phantom Hourglass link
and Tetra continue on with their mission
to find new lands they eventually call
land ho on a new continent which has a
mysterious Tower at its center with a
bunch of rail tracks stemming from it
and despite there clearly being some
form of settlement here Lincoln Tetra
colonized this new land as the New
Kingdom of Hyrule fast forward 100 years
in which going down a new Hyrule the
aforementioned tracks are disappearing
left right and center and the reigning
Princess Zelda wants to know why she
dispatches the descendant of link and an
engineer named Alfonso to go and
investigate turns out that a Shifty
looking politician wearing two hats is
the culprit God I love Nintendo anyway
two hats is called Cole and his ultimate
plan is to resurrect a lad called
maladis a demon king who's sealed at the
top of that aforementioned Tower he
succeeded in part of his plan which is
to separate Zelda from her physical body
to make a vessel for the incoming Demon
King this sort of backfires though as
Spirit Zelda is instrumental in helping
link unify the kingdom relay the spirit
tracks and ultimately defeat malodus
himself who upon release takes on the
form of an evil train as you do and with
Cole and maladis vanquished Lincoln
Zelda are entrusted with caring over the
land and from there the kingdom of new
Hyrule prospers the end
except it's not
[Music]
here's where Nintendo kind of just stops
caring about their own damn timeline you
see breath of the wild wasn't initially
given a placement on the overarching
chronology for a good while after its
release about a year after the game
launched though Japanese publication
famitsu asked the devs the essential
question of where the game sat on the
already convoluted timeline their answer
and I quote was well of course it's at
the very end but I get what you're
asking it's which timeline it's at the
very end of that's up to the player's
imagination isn't it which kinda means
that they just haven't figured that out
yet so let's for a moment entertain this
nonsense and say that breath of the wild
takes place at the end of all of the
timelines it still leaves a lot for the
imagination which I guess is the point
according to the developers anyway
there's plenty of evidence of hyrule's
History across breath of the Wild's vast
map both ancient and recent and by
ancient I mean 10 000 years ago and by
recent I mean a century ago so basically
breath of the wild is potentially so
very far into the future that it's
placement on the timeline doesn't even
matter but hey ho let's get to the story
most of the key narrative beats of
breath of the wild actually take place
through extensive flashbacks during
these we learn that the kingdom of
Hyrule was once a hugely Advanced
civilization and the people used this
technological prowess to protect
themselves from the endlessly repeating
Ganon apocalypse to this end they built
themselves four huge Divine beasts and a
whole Army of Guardian robots to help
them repel the advance of Ganon which
they did yay until the next time Ganon
read his ugly head that is not yay
anyway fast forward to about
to about a century proceeding
hello
anyway fast forward to about a century
preceding the events of breath of the
wild and we catch up with the latest
incarnation of Princess Zelda and the
Beast piloting Champions who are gearing
up for the inevitable next round with
Ganon the latest in the line of zeldas
has not been blessed with the ancient
power of the goddess and in the wake of
that she relentlessly pursues any and
all means with which to hold back the
oncoming Ganon storm unfortunately she
runs out a time before ganon's next
attack and in the ensuing battle her
protector a young lad called link is
hurt fatally wounded at the hands of the
Guardians themselves who have been
possessed by Ganon long story short
Zelda whisks Link away to the shrine of
Resurrection hides the fabled master
sword and in a completely badass move
locks herself and Ganon away in Hyrule
Castle to Duke it out for time Immortal
link the poor lad eventually wakes up
fully healed a whopping 100 years later
with absolutely no memory after a
strange interaction with a wise old man
who turns out to be the long dead Spirit
of the king of Hyrule link Ventures off
on an Epic Quest to take back the four
Divine beasts from Ganon before taking
on the foul Pig himself and after a
lengthy battle link emerges Victorious
and as he and Zelda stand over the
battlefield they look to the Future to
rebuild the devastated Hyrule
[Music]
but that future might have to wait as
there's another destructive force that
wants to end the world of Hyrule for
good or at least that's the direction
that tears of the Kingdom seems to be
going in ostensibly a direct sequel to
breath of the wild tears of the Kingdom
expands the world of Hyrule into the
skies possibly as a throwback to Skyward
Sword right at the very beginning of
this timeline and while there isn't a
whole lot of information to go on right
now that hasn't stopped people from
theorizing about how the last two games
fit into the Zelda Timeline Chief among
those theories is the return of the
Gerudo lad himself Ganondorf Whose
actions pretty much kick-started the
giant chasm in this timeline how this
ties into the wider timeline though is
anyone's guess at the point I'm writing
this which is about a month away from
the release of Tears of the Kingdom but
I'm calling it now my guess is that
breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom slot in at the end of the child
Era timeline only time will tell though
and that Pals is the Zelda Timeline
explained to the best of my ability I
hope you guys enjoy yeah and I like me
looking forward to tears of the Kingdom
if you like these gaming timelines we've
got plenty of the channel already
including Metroid god of war and
Resident Evil thanks for watching guys
I'll see you next time